y al final de cada iteración se organiza una reunión de demostración
para compartir los resultados de lo que hicieron, con transparencia.
Y todos los días, cada miembro del equipo
informa lo que están haciendo de manera individual.
Toda esta transparencia puede resultar incómoda para algunos,
porque de repente ya no hay lugar para ocultarse.
Todo lo que hacemos es transparente para todos.
Conseguir la alineación es complicado
y brindar autonomía no es algo tan obvio tampoco.
A un ejecutivo en otra empresa le gusta hablar de cómo solía ser
un experto en búsquedas.
Ahora, para saber cómo van las cosas,
en lugar de mirar los informes de estado,
necesita ir a donde están los equipos y asistir a una de sus reuniones.
Y en lugar de decir a las personas qué hacer,
busca la manera como ayudarles.
Es un cambio enorme para alguien que solía ser
un experto de las búsquedas.
"Antes", dijo el ejecutivo, "solo tenía la ilusión del control.
En la realidad, muchos proyectos se quedan sin tiempo y sin presupuesto.
Ahora hay mucha más transparencia,
y puedo corregir el curso del proyecto antes, si es necesario".
Y los directivos intermedios deben cambiar también.
Primero, sin las entregas y sin el PowerPoint,
no son tan necesarios los directivos intermedios.
Antes, existía la idea de que había pensadores y realizadores.
Los empleados solo seguían ordenes.
Ahora, en lugar de solo supervisar a otras personas,
se espera que los directivos intermedios sean entrenadores.
Imaginen que en los últimos 10 años,
le han estado diciendo a otros qué hacer,
y ahora se espera que hagan las cosas por su cuenta otra vez.
Es claro que este modelo no es para todos,
y muchas personas dejan la empresa.
Pero el resultado es una nueva cultura con menos jerarquía.
Para esto se necesita mucho trabajo.
Pero vale la pena.
Las empresas con las que he trabajado,
solían introducir características nuevas a un producto algunas veces al año.
Ahora hacen lanzamientos cada par de semanas,
y sin las entregas y la cinta roja,
la organización se vuelve más eficiente.
Y finalmente, si ahora caminas por los pasillos de estas empresas,
sientes una nueva energía.
Se siente como caminar por los pasillos de un gran emprendimiento.
Ahora bien, estas empresas, no pueden cantar victoria aún.
Pero por lo menos con este nuevo modelo,
están mejor preparadas para enfrentar el cambio.
El mundo es cada vez más rápido y más complejo,
por eso necesitamos reiniciar nuestra forma de trabajar.
Y lo más difícil de ese cambio no es la estructura,
ni el proceso o el procedimiento.
Y tampoco se trata de los altos ejecutivos tomando el mando.
Los líderes serán aquellos en la organización
que acepten el cambio.
Todos debemos liderar el cambio.
Así que, la pregunta es: ¿Qué estás dispuesto a abandonar?
Gracias.
(Aplausos)